all right good morning welcome to the
first meeting of the special committee
on housing my name is Joe Alexander I'm
chairman of the committee
um
there are a couple members that will be
arriving late I know of at least two
better at the crash training upstairs
but they said they'd be crass crash but
they'll be down a little later so
um I first want to open it up by
inviting the speaker up to say a few
words about this committee
um why it was formed why it's needed and
then we'll go into introduction so Mr
Speaker
well good morning
um why it was formed as we have a
problem
um and it's it's becoming more and more
of a problem I think every time we talk
to people that uh you know we're trying
to expand and
trying to get new workers into the state
trying to hire more people
and we obviously have a
serious housing problem in this state
so
my goal for this committee is to try and
come up with some answers
nobody knows everybody knows there's no
Magic Bullet
um but there's got to be some ways where
and some things that we can do that's
going to help the situation
help the people that want to hire help
the companies that want to come to the
state
and be able to offer their workers
affordable housing that they can come to
um
there's a lot already out there
I think we have to be realistic about it
uh I I would assume you want to put
everything on the table and then start
sorting through it I know you uh you
know this is an awful lot of people that
want to come in and talk about it
um you know being a uh Board of director
of Southern New Hampshire Services they
definitely said they want to get
involved and try and help because that's
one of the biggest problems they have is
is housing you know for people
so
I I'm not going to propose any answers
to you
I'm not going to tell you what to do and
what not to do
what I'm hoping and that this committee
can come up with some bipartisan answers
that we can move forward with that will
help our
people in this state that are looking
for housing in our business owners that
are looking
to hire more people and the businesses
that would like to maybe come to this
state but can because they can't find a
place
and also that's the same message I want
to give to the children of the child
care committee that we set up because
it's a two-fold problem
uh you know Child Care is is is is just
as much of a problem as housing is right
now
and if we're going to continue moving
forward then we have to find some
answers
that I mean that's it I'm you see I'm
not going to sit here and propose
anything to you but we've got to find
some answers
and hopefully those answers we can put
into bills next uh you know next
September when we have our filing period
or that we do have some bills here that
we might be able to uh put some things
onto between the Senate house bills I'm
sure we could find something if you can
come up with some some some solid
so in your hands right now well thank
you Mr Speaker and thank you for your
leadership on this I know that other
branches of government have looked into
this but I think it's important
um the general court looks at this um in
particular absolutely I mean you know
we're the ones that make the laws
uh you know having said that
I want to make sure that you know
we don't um overreact and try and
trample on any
rights of owners a property or anything
of that nature uh you know and I I think
I'll leave it in your hands see what you
guys can come up with
perfect and when you're done next week
well you know hopefully but
realistically I know this is good this
is going to be a long drawn out process
uh it's very complicated uh it is like I
said we all know there's no silver
bullets that are going to fix the
problem overnight but
um and we're not going to fix the
problem immediately but we've got to
start working on it we've got to start
coming up with some solutions that'll
help
okay so I want to start uh with
introductions so
okay thank you
I think
uh good morning uh I'm Meryl Gibbs um
this is my first term in the legislature
and I represent Concord fort nine
um what's your can you just tell me a
little bit about your experience maybe
with housing or oh yeah thanks
um yes um I'm uh retired from the
federal government
um I worked for 29 years
um
in the U.S Department of Housing and
Urban Development Office of fair housing
and equal opportunity uh I was a manager
in the unit that oversaw civil rights
requirements for HUD grantees uh so I
saw almost all of the grants at one
point or another all the New England HUD
grants
um
generally came across my desk so I know
a lot about housing development and
about other types of things that were
funded by Hud uh and before I went to
the federal government
I was director of the New Hampshire
commission for human rights uh that's
the state civil rights enforcement
agency
thank you Mr chair and thank you um
for taking my introduction my name is
representative Charlotte dilorenzo I
represent New Market in new Fields uh
Rock and Rockingham District 10.
my background is that I am a retired
affordable housing property manager and
I manage housing in Maine New Hampshire
and Massachusetts for the most part
Massachusetts
um and I'm surprised that I
I suppose some of the grants that I
applied were probably one across Merle's
desk while she was working at HUD so
I built kind of a kinship with her but
um my experience was in managing um I
started out managing like single
developments 50 to 75 units
um and then as I
gained you know knowledge and seniority
in my field I went on to make lodged
properties
uh up to
up to 300 units and then I went on to
manage portfolios of affordable housing
most of the work that I did was in
Boston Suffolk County
um
and so I did like day-to-day management
like a property manager sitting at their
desk taking phone calls collecting rents
um
revising our um
creating a budget and then as I you know
gained more experience I manage
portfolios so I would have a bundled
maybe five or six properties that I
would be in and I would supervise all
the employees of that bundle I was also
um responsible for compliance you know
in affordable housing there are many
many many rules and regulations
um
depending on the type of housing that
you're managing I think I've probably
managed uh in every affordable housing
um
genre Genera um from home
funding HUD all types of Hud funding
Mass funding Maine funding New Hampshire
funding so I have a very broad knowledge
the last 10 years of my
career I worked for Pine Street Inn
which is in massachusetts's Wireless
housing
Services Agency and I oversaw their
housing at the time we had about 500
units there were scattered site units
and our job was to assist homeless men
and women to get into housing and that
was um it was like a real challenge for
me it was a wonderful wonderful job I
was sorry that I had to retire
good morning uh my name is
representative Scott Wallace from
Danville Rockingham County District 8
sorry for being late I was up in craze
training
um
my background is a small landlord
primarily single family residences some
commercial we've developed some property
over the years
I've owned an operated tenement
buildings in Haverhill Massachusetts
commercial properties in Lowell and
right now seeing what's going on it
seems to make sense to form this
committee and see what kind of work we
can get done to improve the the housing
dilemma that we Face here in New
Hampshire at this point in time I'm
looking forward to working with all you
folks and hopefully we get these things
done thank you
and Joe Alexander out of Goffstown um so
I've been involved with the housing
issue for since I started in the
legislature four years ago I was brought
in the governor's housing task force
where we
um you know had some policy
recommendations kind of helped Shepherd
some bills through some of these bills
passed some of them didn't but
um this issue has obviously been my
passion for four years now so I'm
excited to get started and hopefully
that we can all come together and find
figure something out here so thank you
hey uh I'm Amber Rudy from Manchester
um
long long time realtor and um
back in the 70s I started putting up
modular homes and some of them were for
there was a loan that was out there
Farmers home loan and it was a good way
for people with very little or no money
to get into a home
well this company I worked with out of
Kennebunk Maine built a special house
for a farmer's Home Loan
and I put one up it went okay and then
after that they would give me an
approval list of about 30 to 45 people a
month who qualified because everybody
wanted one
uh but I found out quickly after doing a
few that there was really no money in it
I could make a lot more money selling a
house getting a commission than I could
by putting up a home that you know for
somebody and it was a great program I
wish I could have continued I wish there
was something that could have been done
to
you know keep the program going and make
it more affordable for Builders to
actually do it so I go way back before
the affordable housing crisis started
now it's a real crisis and of course the
big developers are trying to get into it
and do it and a lot of my friends
several friends I've worked with
four or five people who do developments
with affordable housing and they tell me
all their problems and I said well this
is a good place to air it all out and
maybe we can do something about it I
don't know if we can I know a lot of the
problems come with the local governments
your planning boards and zoning boards
and whatever but this is a great
great effort that we're going to put
forward and hopefully we can come up
with a solution and some of these people
are going to come in and talk to us so
cross our fingers and roll up our
sleeves and maybe we can get something
good morning representative yokella from
Rockingham 32 it's Fremont Danville and
Brentwood
um my history on this is is uh the first
first board I joined in New Hampshire
was the Zoning Board of adjustments so
I've been that is my longest tenure and
that's because you know property rights
are probably the most important thing I
think that um
kind of undergirds all of the other
rights
and so
I'm pretty passionate about that and I
restrictions uh putting their thumb on
the on the scale making it harder for
people to build and to build an
affordable way
and so I definitely would like to look
at that and see if there's uh you know I
do that at the lo my own local level one
of the things that I did was petition
Warren articles just
reading my
local zoning ordinance and all the
things that were inappropriate or just
over restrictive one of the first things
that I ever did was a petition worn
article to change my local sign
ordinance which was 15 pages and I cut
it down to one and a half pages
just through just reading it and and
trying to come up with a common sense
solution that didn't need to be so
complicated and so I've done other
things like that as far as just you know
reading the zoning ordinances that come
across like in trying to trying to make
some sense of it because a lot of it is
put in at different times and not a lot
of people just read the entire thing and
and try and make sense of it and so
there were duplications of stuff that I
tried to clean up and try to identify so
I think that you know the government uh
just making it unclear and making rules
um
you know trying to do their best but not
experts in the situation can sometimes
make make more problems than they're
solving and so that's what one of the
big things that I'm trying to uh
to reduce or make it make it easier for
uh good morning uh representative Josh
adgerton
um from Grafton 16 representing the town
of Enfield
um outside of the legislature I don't
have a whole
um broad bandwidth of experience of the
issue
um as far as being involved in the
actual process however
um I work for Dartmouth Hitchcock
Medical Center up in Lebanon
um and understand how this issue really
plays intersectionally
um because
one of the issues that we're having
right now
um and actually Vice chairman Verdi saw
the same presentation and labor
committee uh was
there's retail which has not really
recovered a lot of jobs post pandemic
and then the next section up above that
is Healthcare
um Dartmouth has gotten around that
right now with the travel Nurse Program
because travel nurses will get a Housing
Voucher and so a lot of their expenses
are covered
um but at some point that's going to end
up raising costs for the hospital to a
point
um where they're going to have to
restrict the travel and there's program
and then they're going to run into the
same
um low staffing issues that surround uh
folks not being able to afford to live
in the Upper Valley
um so I I think that is a pertinent
example of what the speaker mentioned as
far as folks
trying to hire I see that agreement
every day I overheard a charging nurse
the other day say that she had 156
slots to fill and about 80 people worth
of slots to put towards that so
um it is an affordability issue but it
also definitely is a Workforce issue so
I I look forward to seeing us sort that
out and hopefully it leads to a better
smoothing of the economy especially in
highness necessity areas like healthcare
because that is really being hit hard
uh thank you Mr chair my name is Tom
Walsh I'm a representative for Merrimack
County District 10 which is the towns of
Hooksett and Dunbarton starting my sixth
term I've actually been in on the hooks
of planning board for even longer that's
how I get started so I bring 13 plus
years of experience
as both member and chairman of the
planning board I've dealt with all the
different types of housings from cluster
developments to affordable housing to
Workforce housing to high density to
single family your duplex is your
triplexia quads and the pros and cons of
all of them
I don't know really have much else to
add except I've seen a lot of this stuff
and it's not stopping coming from
Hooksett in particular
um obviously being next to Manchester
it's a it's a constant constant swell if
you will of housing moving into Hooksett
um I guess as suggestions go to get
started on this whole process I don't
know what your what your plan is Mr
chair but
right out of the gate I've been thinking
since day one that
I think good practice when you're trying
to solve problems is to figure out what
caused them so I think that would be a
representative Reed
uh my name is Ellen Reed I represent New
Market in new Fields that's Rockingham
10.
um I have seven housing bills in this
year I'm starting my fourth term
I have seven housing bills in this year
including one that I am very hopeful has
in tremendous bipartisan support and as
well as the amazing surprising support
of people like planners Town planners
home builders and Municipal Association
what you know so I'm really hopeful for
that one and happy to talk about that in
detail but in terms of the housing
crisis on the Seacoast my communities
have been hit extremely hard
um this is an economic issue about
Workforce which we all complain about
but more importantly it's a human
emergency
um just in the last few weeks we've had
two people in the state die of exposure
and increasingly the people who are
unhoused are working full-time they are
literally living out of their cars
because simply we don't have anywhere
for them to go we frequently talk about
it this being a supply issue and that's
true and we need to address zoning
issues that restrict the ability to
build and that kind of prioritized rural
character over people's ability to live
we need to address that but we also need
to understand it's not simply a supply
issue in this state and this is far away
and Beyond what the national average is
the national average is that there are
30 three empty homes empty homes
for every single individual unhoused
person in this state it's 74. so it's
not supply it's not purely building it's
building affordably so in addition to
easing restrictions we also have to look
at incentives to build high quality and
I want to stress high quality long term
if we can't keep people in homes long
term because the housing is not good
quality then it doesn't matter because
we're still not creating the stable
communities that have stable Workforce
and stable consumers for our businesses
having said that I keep talking about
the economic factors I still want us to
always stay in touch with the fact that
this is a real human emergency we cannot
lose sight of that many of us have own
our own homes and maybe it's been a
while some of us may own our own homes
outright even we need to to stay in
touch with those actual working class
issues and realize that this is an issue
of whether or not people feel like they
know that they're going to have a roof
over their head in the following month
or they're going to be living out of
their car and what do they do with their
or Cat when they have no place and do
they take their kids out of school and
where do they shower before they go into
work this is a real issue that we need
to constantly stay in touch with the
human aspect of and not only yes address
the economic aspect but not only that
and stay in touch with the human impact
and I guess that's where I'm coming from
thank you
thank you representative for your
introduction
um so as the speaker said I mean this
year we're on a fact-finding mission to
Deep dive into housing crisis so our
goal is to meet with various
stakeholders department heads other
groups there's a couple questions that I
have just starting out but after I'd
love to open it up to what we're in
charge of steering we can steer It
Whatever direction we want to steer it
so I want to open it up to have the
committee contribute but these are the
first things I'm thinking of what kind
of problems do developers encounter when
moving forward with projects how do we
maintain property rights
I'd like to know data on zoning laws
like what the difference between rural
urban zoning laws look like
what changes are towns taking upon
themselves so I'd like to hear from
local I mean I just talked with my town
the chair of the town planning board in
Goffstown this weekend what what changes
are happening on the town level or city
level
what are the conflicts between the state
and local we know some of them but how
can how can we come to you know maybe
there's agreement there how are state
agencies evolved involved is the state
bureaucracy holding up Housing
Development so I want to look at things
like excessive code enforcement
um
I want to look at how the government can
partner with the business Community when
building housing
so in on top of that the committee might
may identify bills as representative
Reed
um pointed out there are bills and other
committees that are that have to do with
housing
um the committee might
um take one or a couple of particular
interests if there's something that we'd
like to to take over we can especially a
retain bill in another committee it
might be something that we could work on
over the summer
um so we're we might identify those
things
um and we can work on that as committees
so we're not expected to have a final
report per se but I do want to come up
with some solid pieces of legislation
for September so we have some sort of a
timeline but the committee is really
um we are free to do what we would like
to do so with that I want to kind of
open it up and see what kind of
Direction
to number one input or whatever
thank you Mr chairman good morning
everyone uh my name is Ben Frost I'm the
deputy executive director and chief
legal officer at New Hampshire housing
um I'm I'm will be happy to do a more
formal presentation about what New
Hampshire housing is and what we do in
the state but I just want to indicate
that uh we are essentially the the go-to
place for data on housing in the state
and we will be happy to serve this
committee uh in any way that we can and
to try to provide data and information
analysis uh that you may may ask for so
we're very interested in in what you do
very grateful to the speaker for forming
the committee and really happy to be
here
anyone else would like to come up and
good morning my name is Adam Schmidt I'm
a lobbyist here in Concord one of the
clients that I work with is the New
Hampshire Association of Realtors
they're very interested in the subject
matter obviously the chairman has
reached out to see if they might be able
to come in and share some information
with the committee I've confirmed that
they're willing to do that so we'll work
on the date and time and they can come
in and
share what information you have in there
push your button for me thank you
Don McKinney uh policy director at New
Hampshire legal assistance we one of our
largest projects is related to housing
um we assist low-income individuals and
families mainly around fair housing and
then landlord tenant law and we
are currently operating eviction clinics
and some of the main courthouses in the
state and mainly Manchester and Nashua
and then some other
um as needed based on the scheduling of
landlord tenant cases so
uh that's kind of our interest is just
making sure that those folks are
getting Fair
um fair treatment and that their rights
are protected and we're trying to really
the what's really the goal of avoiding
further homelessness because we know
that
um
once you lose your housing it's harder
to get back into housing and it ends up
costing our society financially as well
as in other ways so
just leave it at that
and we're happy to we're always happy to
present to you about the work we're
doing but I'll let the chairman decide
like when and how he'd like that to
happen
what's not planning on speaking today
my name is Lara McIntyre I work at Chien
Finney Capital group and I represent two
clients that have an interest in in
housing one is the New Hampshire
community action programs they do a lot
of work uh you know they have a lot of
contracts recording
housing especially with the hotels the
federal programs the emergency rental
assistance I believe that's what it's
called also one of our clients is
Continuous Care and assisted living
facilities nursing nursing care and they
come at it as a employer and the
difficulties that they're facing hiring
people because of
of the lack of affordable housing
good morning everybody my name is Jack
Ruderman I work with Ben Frost at New
Hampshire housing I work on legislative
affairs my title is public affairs
manager and I'm part of our
policy planning and Communications
Division and has been alluded to we do a
lot of research and we issue reports so
for instance we put together the annual
residential rent survey you know which
gives us a very queer picture uh of
where costs are in a given year and what
the trends are and how much things have
gone up or have come down
and I think that that is one publication
that I think that gets a fair amount of
use and is referenced frequently we also
do research on projects key policy
issues so for instance at the moment
we're working on a study on Accessory
dwelling units or adus and should have a
report
sometime by the end of March is our our
Target there was an article over the
weekend in the New York Times about
granny Flats as they are sometimes
called or adus so in any event
um we um we've got a good team
um following some of the key issues in
housing and uh I'll just you know Echo
Ben's comments we're really excited that
this committee has been formed and look
forward to being helpful in any way that
we can
thank you
um
of course pointed out I I love the idea
of adus I'd like to look more into that
co-ops smaller tiny homes maybe for
um
younger people just uh trying to find
their first home or even the elderly
trying to settle down to something a
little smaller for them so I like to
open it up to the committee
um you know I have
stakeholders I'd like to hear from
including the New Hampshire realtors New
Hampshire Housing Finance
um I I'm a Cena's Hawk and I think St
Anson college has a lot of good things
around zoning and they just published a
uh a zoning report so I'd like to hear
from them as well but
um I'd like the committee to weigh in
Mr chair I I would like to include in
the list of shareholders all those who
are present today their organizations
New Hampshire housing also Seacoast
Workforce housing and legal assistance
uh it there may be other groups to add
to that but I want to make sure that
both sides of the coin are represented
um because while we can help industry we
also need to make sure that we're
producing the outcomes that we want
um representative okay
thank you Mr chairman
um in order to get a unit that's
affordable
we have to get there and a way to get
there is with the people who invest in
rehabs or construction to build the
units to make them more affordable and I
have a list of people that I've worked
with in the past
contractors investors
that would like to come in and tell us
how they number one get their money
their funding
construction people on on construction
different types of construction I know
when I did my my housing for Farmers
home loan the materials were entirely
different they were subgrade but um
that's all we could use to get people in
and that's another reason why I wouldn't
do them anymore but um and then we have
the managers and what they the problems
that they have so in order for somebody
to move into a unit we have to make it
available to get there and how do we do
that what's the cost what's the hurdles
what's uh and I think that hearing from
these people who are in the trenches
doing all the work I think it's very
important that we hear from them
okay representative Gibbs and then
representative
thank you
um things that I want to mention are the
um barriers to the development of
affordable housing that I saw while
working at HUD as I said for 29 years
um and there are a number of them
um I guess the most obvious one up front
is always going to be funding uh but one
thing that I saw over the course of time
was how much more complex the funding
became
um
I saw many many proposals for affordable
housing development some which succeeded
some of which didn't but in the
beginning
um very often the funding was the
funding from the um uh applicant for the
grant and the funding uh that they would
um uh request to receive from HUD
sometimes also they were requesting some
funding from say the New Hampshire
Housing Finance Authority uh but by the
time I left in 2016
most of the project proposals that we
saw had
about a dozen funding sources attached
they were so complex and obviously the
more funding sources were attached the
more requirements that you had from from
each funding source the more complex it
was to put them all together to get all
the stakeholders to agree so I'm not
making any suggestions as to how to
address that I'm just bringing that
forward as a problem that I saw that
developed over time
that something that we're going to need
to work with the second barrier that I
saw and this is something that is
certainly not true only in New Hampshire
but all over New England and I would
think all over the country is
exclusionary zoning
um that is um uh zoning that
um uh forbids multi-family housing
um and sometimes even for single-family
housing where you have the requirement
for very large lot sizes
um to the point where it becomes
impossible uh to create affordable
housing because it simply can't it can't
be affordable if the lot size is an acre
um so that's again that's another
problem some other states have dealt
with this
um by legislation in Massachusetts
um uh courts have dealt with it in some
other states as in New Jersey
um honestly the the success of these
attempts have been limited
um but this is uh always a serious
barrier and again one that we're going
to have to work with and the last thing
I wanted to mention
um
and I was interested to hear
representative
um yokola I'm sorry am I yokella thank
you uh representative yokella mentioned
um excessive code enforcement
um and that was wasn't something
um that honestly I would would not have
phrased it that way myself uh uh or
certainly not have not phrased it but I
have seen
that type of activity be a problem
um we're code enforcement has been used
in what I can only describe as a
discriminatory way
um that is and again I was in the office
of fair housing the the Civil Rights
um unit and we saw this
um sometimes used by cities and towns
um against certain groups
um that is the code enforcement was
stricter against some groups than
against others also sometimes
um it was used to keep out families with
children and
this is something
um discrimination against family with
children is illegal under both uh
federal fair housing law and under the
New Hampshire laws against
discrimination uh it is nevertheless as
I'm sure you all know uh still quite
common and something that has been very
common
um for many many years
back uh when I was director of the New
Hampshire Human Rights Commission
um uh and I left there in in 1987 before
it became illegal to discriminate
against families with children
but one of the most shocking uh things
that I can remember was
um people coming to us
families with children who were living
in their cars in the winter in New
Hampshire because they could not find a
landlord willing to rent to people with
children and
that that was a terrible thing uh to
hear about
um so I think those issues of Code
Enforcement can also be a barrier thank
you thank you and I think um like I said
saint ansem College came out with a
great study regarding exclusionary
zoning and the color map of areas of the
state which units can be built and and
how and the zoning laws so I'd love to
kind of see that and have them speak to
that research so thank you
representative thank you Mr chairman um
on the topic of zoning
um on sort of a cosmic level I would
encourage the committee to think about
longevity
um you know there's the old quote uh
where Tony Soprano says buy land because
they stopped making it
um
this is going to be a thing
um where you know you look at
restricting or you look at easing zoning
restrictions and I know that I will want
to make sure as part of that compromise
um that there is an active effort to
build
um involved in that process too because
one thing that has always worried me is
that uh easing those restrictions
without a guarantee of building is how
you end up with you know somebody taking
50 acres of land that could otherwise be
used for development and building a
multi-million dollar home on it there's
always going to be a larger profit
incentive for those sort of 50 acre
developments than there would be for
affordable housing so I'm not inherently
against uh easing zoning restrictions I
think that would be a good thing but I
do want to make sure that there's also
an additional emphasis on actually
producing the units
um before letting those floodgates open
um and then just again the longevity of
it because you you know this is going to
be a problem so long as there are people
on the Earth and I would hate for us to
solve this problem for five or ten years
and then have to be back here with
another select house committee
um in 5 10 20 years uh looking at all
the same problems really trying to make
sure that we're utilizing
um the land that we have in the most
productive and effective way possible
um because they're not making any more
of it
thank you representative Reed
thank you so
my earlier comment about both sides of
the coin I think rep adjutant touched on
that and that is to say that while I
agree with a lot of zoning regulations
that need to be undone in communities
because there's been a kind of
traditionalist stick in the mud
mentality about what those towns what
the people in those towns who perhaps
already own their homes are outright
want those towns to look like in the
idea of rural character for example lot
minimums I think is something that we
can talk about because
a lot there's ways to increase density
and reduce those lot minimums while
retaining rural character there's a
design is actually what I got my
master's degree in a design called open
clusters designs which really retains
that role character while having much
smaller lot minimums increase density
there's also multi-family housing
designs that don't look multi-family at
all and again I think that the point is
to one of the points needs to be to make
sure that we're doing high quality
housing so while we're using
restrictions and going into partnership
with industry we still need we have
leverage we still need to make that when
make sure that when that happens we have
a threat threshold that we want to make
sure gets met and we're getting the
outcomes that we want I was glad to hear
the chair bring up tiny homes if you'll
permit me a one minute story there was a
man in my region actually in the town of
Lee and I don't know if anybody here
represents Lee uh named Peter McDonald
who himself he was a vet and had spent
some time homeless
as a result of his wounds he later in
his years when he he came into the
ability to own property he had bought 12
acres and went on a big campaign to do
tiny homes for homeless vets and had
showcased at all the fairs these tiny
homes that he had built for homeless
vets they were completely well appointed
and amazing things I donated money to
him a small amount but he was he was
really pushing for something great the
town of Lee eviscerated him completely
destroyed him in stymied him at every
turn I think it went to court and he
ended up passing away and there was
quite a bit of stress in his life and I
don't know to what extent that
contributed to his passing but
um that's the kind of thing I would like
to see us actually incentivize and help
out and certainly not prohibit
um so I that's something I want to raise
also obviously at any point this
committee is ready to talk about adus I
am here I do have lots of support on my
current Adu bill
thank you representative Delorenzo
thank you Mr chair um
said I'm interested in is Thinking Out
of the Box about housing models and I
noticed that
the malls are dying shopping malls are
dying and I thought what a wonderful
resource to build a community around
I think you could have like you could
have home ownership like in condos you
could have retail you could have
educational facilities and work sites
right there so you have a contained
Community I think that's something that
me we may want to think about pursuing
at some point I think it's down the road
maybe 10 years but I think we need to
think about that I love that idea where
and we're supposed to be creative here
representative just really quickly
because I representative De Lorenzo
reminded me of something I wanted to say
which is in addition because I know a
lot of what we're doing is focusing on
rentals and the ability to create
rentals in affordable high quality
rentals I also want this committee to
focus on the problem of home ownership
because when we're talking about the
housing crisis we're talking about the
biggest crisis in the state but we're
also talking about the second biggest
crisis in the state which is the graying
of New Hampshire and the fact that we
cannot keep in and attract young people
simply because there's nowhere for them
to affordably live so I think increasing
the uh or decreasing the barriers to
home ownership in the state which
includes increasing affordability
um whether by addressing property tax
issues or other Market issues is
something that I would like this
committee to look into
representative Wallace thank you yes
that's uh reusing repurposing and
recycling any existing structures that
are currently vacant is it is an
excellent way to move forward thinking
outside the box
um and also embracing the new technology
of building
um that is on the edge of the market a
lot of these uh other parts of the world
and parts of the country using 3D
printed homes with styrofoam concrete
reinforced styrofoam it's very thermally
efficient a blended approach like that
including reform of the snob zoning I
mean let's face it got 2 000 square foot
minimums on a two and a half acre house
lot
um isn't going to work in this market in
some communities but uh you know there's
got to be a we can find a maybe a
balance you know with these additional
dwelling units tiny homes maybe that
goes to a thousand square feet in some
of these communities at least it gives
you the ability because right now to go
and build a you know a 2 000 square foot
on a first floor home
let's face it you're going to be
spending in the vicinity of a half a
million dollars presently that's
probably not affordable for most young
people in first time home buyers we've
got to get down into that sweet spot in
the 250 the 350 range and you know a
thousand feet on the first floor might
get us in that neighborhood with a half
acre lot
foreign
I'm a little bit more ambitious than uh
to two to three hundred thousand dollars
for a home and actually I I do mostly
think about it more as home ownership
than than rental I think of it as
um
like the home that I bought was a
hundred thousand dollars I want I want
why aren't we building a hundred
thousand dollar homes
on and is it illegal in the state of New
Hampshire to build a hundred thousand
dollar home when when there are places
in the state that have 10 acre minimum
lot requirements
yes that it is illegal to build a
hundred thousand dollar home in that in
that part of the state right and so
um and also someone was mentioning
um that how how people have over time
like my my hundred thousand dollar house
is built on 0.17 Acres right and now my
town has a two acre lot requirement so
my home to build in my community
matching the character of my street is
illegal like you can't one street over
build New Lots the exact same that my
street is
why is that illegal
um it's not because of the historical
character my house has been there since
the 50s right and it's pre-even
um some of these more restrictive zoning
stuff and so I think that
um a lot of that sometimes they're using
that stuff as excuses of uh because
there already are places in the past
that have built in on smaller lot sizes
um and it didn't I my my neighbors are
not hurting me and and we get all along
just fine right and so it's not harming
the people around it
um I think that um tiny tiny homes
um things built you know uh that someone
could buy for under a hundred thousand
dollars that they could get a 30 year
mortgage on and essentially any job in
the state could be able to afford the
rent of it
or the mortgage of it because it's you
know 400 a month
that is what what
um helps like that first starter person
that right now there are so many people
my age that are well maybe a little bit
younger than me now that I'm getting
older but are able are not able to get
into their first home because all the
houses are five hundred thousand dollars
and you have to be making you have to be
essentially married and have two incomes
to be able to afford a single mortgage
and so
yeah
um and so where is that that person that
is 20
that has a full-time job that is wanting
to um you know either rent or buy why
aren't both of those options available
to them because there's no houses that
are possible to be bought at that uh
that rate and these people aren't asking
for you know mcmansion they just want a
place that that um
that they can that they can call their
own and possibly you know once they pay
off that then use that Equity to to get
into something nicer when they want to
start a family because a lot of the
times some some of these restrictions
are people aren't uh especially at
zoning and zba and when we're we're
trying to change some of that stuff and
allow housing to come in people are are
very worried about children coming in
and
um and because they're very expensive to
to teach at the school level
um and so there there is still some
discrimination as far as like we don't
want to allow this development or or
work we're concerned about this
development because it's going to cost
our taxpayers a lot of money
if they if they happen to have kids or
something like that but
um some of these smaller homes that my
house is not even a thousand square feet
um
I you know there's only so many kids I
could possibly have in my place right
because it's not that big and so if you
build these really small starter homes
they are not necessarily putting a lot
of of uh effort on the on the school
system because there's just not enough
room to have those those these are
starter
um starter homes right where you're just
starting out you don't have kids you're
not married all of that stuff and
um so this would uh create taxpayers
that aren't really over overburdening
the the school system and would help
them to be able to get the to those 300
to 500
000 homes
that representative Wallace was talking
about so thanks thank you and I find it
I actually find it truly unfortunate
that my two bedroom townhouse the
mortgage on that is
significantly less than what it would
cost somebody to rent a two-bedroom
townhouse in the state and that just
goes to the the the lack of supply of
like less homes but less like smaller
lesser value homes so
representative Reed at risk of speaking
too much I just want to lift up
everything that representative yokella
just said I think he saw me violently
nodding my head throughout the entire
thing and I think that addressing home
ownership
has the market effect of bringing down
rental rates anyway so if we get to that
core because I think it's it's almost
animalistic in its need it's you know
Maslow's you know hierarchy that we have
a place every animal has its den we need
a place to call our own and as while
people can live long-term in rentals if
you want truly stable communities
homeownership benefits pretty much every
single metric in communities so really
overcoming those barriers to home
ownership is is really important there
was another thing that you reminded me
to say but I forget it now so I'm just
going to tell you how great you are
in on this because we can't agree on
everything
I know that um
we all have good ideas on how to
make things more affordable but
a lot of the problem is us us meaning
the state of New Hampshire the local
zoning and planning boards nobody's
going to want to give up any of their
power
and that's where your resistance is
going to come from no matter what kind
of ideas we have you still have the
state with the vpa laws I know last week
A house came on the market I called a
client boom we went and looked at it it
was under agreement for six weeks
it couldn't get financing because they
were going FHA and the well was too
close to the septic system
by not very much so they couldn't buy
that house so my client went in
conventional loan boom we're all set
so these FHA buyers have these
guidelines FHA guidelines that are going
to restrict them on a lot of things
our our state government with their EPA
laws are going to restrict people also
so where do we start I think we start at
the top and look at our state laws and
only we can change those
okay that's something that we can we can
change
these other things
um people selling their homes in
Massachusetts coming up and outfitting
every young couple who's been saving for
five years to get their first home I'd
hate to be a young couple trying to get
my first home being outbid from somebody
from out of state because they just sold
their house for a lot of money they came
in with cash I don't have a prayer and
and I see more and more of that these
young people that are really struggling
cannot buy out their first home
I I'm a single guy I I'm showing a
restaurant this afternoon but I've sold
a lot of restaurants uh and so I eat out
all the time
three bartenders that I know
have to leave to move in with their
parents because their landlord's gone up
on their rent so much one of them had to
move to Massachusetts to live with her
parents
this is a problem that I don't know if
we can fix because
supply and demand it's whatever the
market will bear and these landlords are
going to charge what they can charge
and there's nothing stopping them so we
have to look at the new either new
construction or loosen up some state
laws because I don't think this the
cities and towns are going to loosen up
that much it's going to be a battle and
if we can get around it and and somehow
get them to come around that's going to
be a big challenge I think
representative
yeah thank you Mr chair
um full disclosure to to prove that I am
here in a positive manner I did live in
a mobile home I loved it I wish I was
still in it because I would have retired
by now so
um but like I said before I'm still a
firm believer that they get to solve
problems we need to get to the root of
how we got here so in general terms I
think it would be good information CNAs
might be able to help with this because
I have seen a few of their studies how
long have we been trending in this
direction is it something that's been
happening because of spikes or has it
been a gradual thing I don't know
um as representative Broody said the
coveted migration
did how much of an impact did that have
nobody wants to talk about it I'm sure
but in terms of affordable housing
what's the impact of illegal immigration
and people seeking Asylum just looking
for a better life these people are
moving somewhere and I have a funny
feeling they're in what used to be the
affordable housing for your bartenders
waitresses and everybody else why I
think it's important because some of
these problems are created by the
federal government and so if we're
looking for Solutions then maybe we
should be looking at them for some of
the financial
help
some of this other information I just
jot it down again that sane as may help
and maybe other resources
um and and some of this I think was
touched on it I just think it's
important information to have
I think you already mentioned it how
many what are what and how many towns
are already doing things to solve this
problem because he knows about it now
um I know we're in in Hooksett we're
currently going through our master plan
draft as well you know and a lot of
these changes uh are being suggested
we're also waiting to get the results of
our housing needs assessment that's
being done through the Southern New
Hampshire Planning Commission
um another good question to ask how many
towns municipalities currently
um comply with the statute that already
is in the books in terms of its
percentage of affordable housing there
is a statute that says you need to have
a percentage of units that are
affordable and be interesting to see how
this works by the region
um other ones too where
who's not increasing their stock in
their inventory I can tell you right now
Hooksett were sitting on almost 1100
approvals
for for residents uh some singles some
multi-family two apartment buildings one
400 unit assisted living facility
um it's just a myriad across the board
so I mean it's not that we're not
growing in Hooksett but I did see a
study somewhere and I can't remember
where it was from that it showed at a
lot of this towns in Southern New
Hampshire especially Merrimack Valley
have been increasing two to three
hundred percent over the last 10 years
in stock in inventory
but then the municipalities your larger
ones your Manchester's your nashuas
we're only increasing at 40 percent
so I I just think it would be
interesting to see what the trends are
who's doing what uh in terms of making
decisions on what needs to change at the
state level
um I think representative baruti is
going to be our biggest one I think
other developers should be coming in
here to give us the challenges of why
these things aren't affordable to build
without funding wow so that's
information I welcome with open arms the
only thing I'll say in in in
rebut to something representative Broody
said about it's about the planning and
power of uh that the power of planning
and zoning boards
I've been doing this for 13 years I
don't look at my position on the
planning board of having anything to do
with power the power in these decisions
on the zoning ordinance is the people
that live there
right now Hooksett is one of many towns
that still allows the basically a
referendum for the people of the town to
decide because you have to agree it's a
trust what they want their future to
look like there is currently a challenge
by the Town Council to strip the
citizens of that decision and to put it
within the hands of the council I am
adamantly against that we want to talk
about a bill prohibiting that might be
all ears for that but this is and I
agree this is challenging and there's a
lot of different angles to this and I
just think as many things as we can get
from information to get started will put
us in the place we need to be to start
picking away at it thank you go ahead
represent Bertie thank you Mr chairman
um for the record I've never had a
problem with the hooks at planning board
but but um
the point that I made was probably a
personal experience I had just before
covert I was doing a subdivision
in Laconia
and it took us 14 months to get approval
and we went in every every month we'd go
in and did exactly what they told us to
do and then finally when there was
nothing else to be said or done one of
the members said I just don't like this
project because I'm in a butter
that's where it comes in it's the local
people with personal reasons why
something won't in these small towns you
can't get a small town without somebody
having a personal reason or whatever
goes on there
and it wasn't a geared towards toxic but
we we have a lot of small towns and I
think a lot of small towns do have snob
zoning I did the first cluster for
development in the town of Auburn
it was on the books it was legal we went
in we mapped it all out and they held us
up
and that was another 14-month process
in the middle they changed the zoning
from two acres to two acres here and
three acres over here they just totally
knocked us off rail
so this is a personal thing with
planning boards that do things that have
if we did get it through but we lost a
couple of units
so representative Walston representative
yeah thank you Mr chair I don't disagree
representative Rudy that there are some
towns that probably operate like that I
don't know if it's the majority
I know I have a speech rehearsed to all
the butters that we as a planning board
are simply here to enforce the ordinance
that are before us and our development
regulations if there are issues between
the the Butters and the developers we do
the best we can to you know find
Solutions but but I don't know
or I don't I don't want to believe that
it's that widespread that there are that
many zoning boards that would use that
kind of abuse so something we can
certainly look at I just wanted to
mention it
developer it's got a lot of money
invested in a project a lot of time a
lot of money and to get thrown off track
because of personal reasons and it does
happen in smaller towns representative
Reed so thank you Mr chair
um a lot of the data that the
representative is saying we need I
absolutely agree I agree with all the
data that he said we need I'm hoping a
lot of it might be provided by New
Hampshire housing hopefully and I'm
seeing nods all right so I look forward
to to those presentations and that
documentation because it is something we
really do need to get into the weeds and
and study this and get into the numbers
um as far as you know uh zoning and how
much of a problem it is I just have two
very quick because I also by the way
something else you touched on
um you know not just mobile homes which
any more excellent but all other kinds
of kind of non-conventional housing
things like Quonset homes which have
become a huge thing extremely
inexpensive and easy to put up but more
weather durable than even a stick built
um thing modular homes these things we
should be investigating these things and
making sure that towns are not unfairly
prohibiting them or just even
accidentally them but in terms of zoning
the two quick anecdotes I had an idea
for a bill which I ended up putting in
when I put it in all of my co-sponsors
were of the opposite party from me but
at the time I had the idea I asked a
representative who was of the same party
as me and it was to address what is a
regressive tax structure which is
property tax which effectively taxes
people out of their ability to own a
home to the point that you could inherit
a home outright and not be able to live
in it so I was trying to address this in
a fair way and the member that I
proposed the idea to who was of my party
said well if you do that you'll be
attracting all the wrong kinds of people
so yeah and I was like and it's just of
my own party I'm like what
um and then the other anecdote is when I
was trying to address the Adu situation
before covet before the crisis was as
bad as it is now
I called my town planner asking why we
were prohibiting
um adus from being built within a
completely pre-existing built within
completely within a pre-existing
detached structure because what does it
matter you've already got the footprint
down you've already approved the
structure let someone live there you
can't even tell if you're driving by if
someone lives in the garage and she goes
oh because I'm talking about the need
for more housing and she goes we already
do enough for this is our town planner a
previous Town planner not our current
one we already do enough for those
people they have the trailers and they
have the apartments to which I had to
rebut I am one of those people and I'm
also one of your representatives so
um I have a problem with that so this is
what we're battling that you know and I
I feel like it might be generational not
to offend anybody I apologize it's it's
this broad stroke for sure but there
seems to be
um an old-fashioned mindset about what
we want our towns to look like which
doesn't match the realities today
because you can't just go and buy like
people used to for like one or two years
income buy a house anymore there's no
five-digit houses on the market anymore
so thank you
go ahead
myself
I want my town to have my kids living
here and not have to move out of state
because they can't afford to live here
or get a good job that's what I want my
town to look like my town in the last
year has had hundreds of people and
these are our postal workers our
restaurant workers young professionals
and Veterans have been pushed out not
just out of our town but out of our
entire region and out of the state in
many cases so I sympathize
representative
did you have something oh I I just
wanted to say um the syndrome that we're
talking about is NIMBY not in my
backyard yes
yes thank you um so regarding next steps
I think we kind of got a good idea of
what we want to do
um do Fridays or Mondays work I heard
from representative agiton has a
conflict on Mondays but does Fridays
work for everyone
no
longer
um unfortunately with I'm on the
Commerce Committee and um the Commerce
Committee is very very busy uh to the
point where
um uh tomorrow Wednesday and Thursday we
have we have Commerce Committee um
meetings and and hearings and it seemed
like
um uh okay this maybe just me I don't
know uh but the only if I have any
personal business the only day that I'll
have available uh will be Friday
um and I guess I was hoping that um if
this committee met it it might be more
likely to be on Monday I mean I'll I'll
adjust to whatever I have to because I
think this committee is very important
um I guess I'm just putting in a plug
um for Monday if possible okay
um I'm going to try to schedule
represent Broody and I came up with one
Friday moving forward in the middle of
February but I think a lot of our
committee responsibilities will end
um towards the end of February early
March we should get most of those bills
out of committee
um so I'm looking at
um February 17th starting at 10 A.M have
a little bit of a day of it maybe listen
to a couple presentations in the morning
couple in the afternoon I've already
extended invites to the New Hampshire
Realtors to give us a whole
all-encompassing
um
description of what's going on
um we're going to have a couple
developers come in and tell us what
their roadblocks are from beginning
beginning to end uh representative Rudy
will send the invites out and then I'll
also send an invite to Saint ansem
college for them to do their
presentation on zoning and see if
they're available to do that as well so
is there anybody I mean we're gonna this
is like the most Broad and we're gonna
try to zero in once we get more
information but is there anybody else
you'd like to hear from in that meeting
as I mentioned at the beginning I would
like to hear from New Hampshire housing
as well as New Hampshire legal
assistance for what the needs actually
are so when we get the data from
Builders we can kind of match need with
with obstacles back to scheduling are
you planning Mr chair on every Monday
except for the week of the 13th in which
case it'll be Friday or is it the next
one is the 17th the next meeting will be
the 17th and then we'll look forward
after that okay thank you representative
thank you Mr chairman I know you're on
Judiciary and they're hearing a lot of
real estate bills
can you pull together some of the bills
that might we might look at
to have problems that we might be
addressing here
yes
um representative Delorenzo can help
with that as well
um we heard a number of landlord tenant
bills last week
um representative Reed some of
Representative Reed's bills and uh
moving forward I think there's some
where you can find compromise I'm
looking at
um particular uh the application fee one
we may be able to but like I said I
think if these are bills that committees
are retaining
um or you know holding on to for
whatever reason we can ask that those
come to this committee and kind of work
on those as well but representative they
come to our committee but look at it to
see if we have a solution to whatever
problem okay that's a I think that's a
good idea but also I would like to make
sure we do not forget Municipal
committee because there are a number of
housing bills in the municipal committee
some of which they've already execed but
I think it's still Worth US looking and
kind of maybe coming up with language
proposed for a future year
and and just to add a lot of these bills
may be tabled and we're able to look at
those bills or put them onto a bill that
we end up coming together next year as
long as they're not itl'd and they're
um I first of all um I want to support
representative Reed about um needing to
work with the municipal committee
because I I think it's almost certain
that a lot of the issues that we need to
deal with in regard to zoning
um uh will be before the municipal
committee and then
um uh back to scheduling
um
okay I don't want to create a problem
and I will reschedule if I have to but
I'm afraid the 17th was the day I loaded
um
but if it's the 17th um I'll I'll do
whatever I can to reschedule them just
to offer a possibility
um understanding that this is after a
two-day session a potential two-day
session in the beginning of February
break um I don't have anything on the
24th
so I'm going to have the committee stand
by on a future date and I'll look with
consultation with rapper Rudy on a day
for us moving forward
um
and we will um I'll coordinate with the
relevant stakeholders and make sure they
get invites to this and I'm hoping to do
like kind of a longer day with this so
we can have you know three or four
pretty heavy presentations and get a
holistic approach to this so maybe a
morning and afternoon session so
um with that does anybody else go ahead
so sorry should I go ahead and
reschedule those things for the 17th or
wait until
um if if you can and just follow up with
me in the next couple next day or two
that'd be helpful for us because I can't
start scheduling these stakeholders
until right we have to right okay
started that as quickly as I can thank
it's penciled yes
pencil it in
right is there anything else come before
a committee
oh I I'm on Municipal and County
government so
um I can uh
and I don't care which Friday or Monday
um but uh I think a lot of the stuff
coming out of Municipal and county is
going on consent and we're pretty much
going to be done I think we have like
six more bills to be to hear and then
we're gonna like exec everything and
maybe we have some second committee
bills or something but pretty much
everything is going to be disposed of
pretty
soon out of Municipal and County
Government
but I do think it's a good point that
even if we table them on the floor they
can be reintroduced for next year
or right a version that we work on I
mean yeah right but if they're itl even
on consent if they're itl'd then uh no
representative would be able to bring
forward substantially substantively
similar language next year so that might
be something to uh say to your committee
if there's ever a possibility that
instead of itl and you can table it
um that might be something or retain it
that would be something helpful for us
I'm not sure that we
yeah thank you um yeah I'm not sure that
the housing stuff I'm not sure that we
have exact yet
um
but well yeah
that that's
yeah that's
um I don't think that that's
I think that one what is going on the um
on the floor
the big one is is on the floor was not
consented to but the informational only
one was
informational one
I'm not I'm not sure exactly perfect so